hi everyone my name is Jack Wallace and
I'm a dialect coach here in Hollywood
today I'm going to be trying to find out
who has the authentic New York accent if
you are going into court you need this
person with you a lawyer if you up in
the morning you go to Dunkin Donuts you
have your donut and you have coffee and
is it cold usually it's hot those two
words together hot coffee briefly tell
me about some of your tattoos they are a
different mix of things this is my
science arm I probably have like three
different x's on my body somewhere what
what do you like to do it's like
spending out of town with my daughter I
edit a lot watch a lot of movies like
Kung Fu movies and things like that
what's the like typical snack at a
baseball game
my final guess
for this it's gonna be
Zeus
[Music]
now in New York here I am a dialect
coach and I was fooled